bewährungsprobe er bog in moskau jetzt
in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
ich bin mit einer dicken gesprächs mappe
gekommen sie ist dick weil es eine ganze
reihe von themen zu besprechen gibt in
denen wir große teils fundamentale
meinungsverschiedenheiten
haben sie ist aber auch so dick weil es
so viele themen gibt bei dem wir chancen
für mehr zusammenarbeit sehen
soweit die deutsche außenministerin
annalena baerbock heute in moskau bei
ihrem antrittsbesuch auf einer
pressekonferenz und damit herzlich
willkommen bei uns meine gäste zunächst
die zugeschalteten es ist jürgen trittin
bei uns von bündnis 90/die grünen
außenpolitischer sprecher der fraktion
im bundestag mitglied im auswärtigen
ausschuss und stellvertretender
vorsitzender der deutsch russischen
parlamentariergruppe
klaus von dohnanyi ist ebenfalls bei uns
lang langjähriges spd-mitglied von ihren
vielen funktionen nämlich jetzt mal den
ersten früheren ersten bürgermeister der
freien und hansestadt hamburg sie haben
ein buch neulich herausgebrachten dem
titel nationale interessen deutsche und
europäische politik in zeiten globaler
umbrüche da geht es auch um das
verhältnis zu russland hier im studio
hat mir melnik ukraine expertin am
institut für europäische politik und
professor johannes farbig ist bei uns
experte für internationale politik an
der universität in halle herr von
dohnanyi das mit spannung erwartete
austreten von annalena baerbock in
moskau vor der presse dass wir da heute
gesehen haben hat sie das überzeugt wir
haben sie einen titel schon erwähnt hat
sie die
bewährungsprobe bestanden
ich finde sie hat das gut gemacht wenn
man bedenkt dass sie eine weite strecke
gehen musste während des wahlkampfs und
davor hatte sie ja immer eine position
die sage ich mal sehr stark auf der
moralischen seite auf der seite der
menschenrechte in russland usw
orientiert war und jetzt hatte sie
natürlich die notwendigkeit sich mit den
realitäten und mit den forderungen auf
der russischen seite auseinanderzusetzen
und ich finde sie hat dass unter diesen
umständen hat sie das wirklich gut
gemacht und ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
war darüber überrascht
trittin jetzt trotz dessen was oder
trotzdem was herr von dohnanyi gerade
gesagt hat über die menschenrechts
basierte außenpolitik für die ihre
partei ja steht und die ja vor allem der
ja vor allem auch die zukunft gehören
soll lässt lassen sich denn damit
internationale konflikte wie zum
beispiel diesen mit russland tatsächlich
lösen mit einer vor allen dingen
menschenrechts passierten außenpolitik
ist das realistisch
offensichtlich denn der letzte termin
deren annalena baerbock in moskau
gemacht hat hat sie zur
menschenrechtsorganisation memorial
memorial geführt jene menschenrechts
organisationen die die statistischen
verbrechen in russland aufarbeitet und
die in der weihnachtspause von einem
gericht in russland verboten wurde ich
glaube es ist richtig dass frau berbalk
dort sehr tough aufgetreten ist aber
dass sie eben auch betont hat was die
gemeinsame geschichte zwischen deutschen
und russen ist und das ist die deutschen
waren die einst in den vierzigerjahren
russland mit krieg überzogen und
überfallen haben und gleichzeitig an die
verantwortung auch klartext geredet
haben das alle verantwortung gibt für
russland für die sicherheit in europa
und das dazu es nicht passt über 100.000
soldaten an der grenze zur ukraine
stationiert zu haben das sei eine droge
die reise von annalena baerbock die
führte ja zunächst mal über kiew nach
moskau das war ja auch ganz bewusst zum
gewählt gestern in kiew war sie mit
ihrem amtskollegen zusammen auch mit dem
präsidenten des landes wie hat denn die
ukrainische öffentlichkeit soweit man
das jetzt schon feststellen kann auf
diese pressekonferenz mit dem russischen
außenminister sergej lawrow auf den
reagiert ich habe persönlich auch
erwartet dass dieser pressekonferenz
mehr schlagzeilen in der ukraine
erzeugen wird und das war nicht der fall
es gab ganz andere jetzt
nachrichten die in den mittelpunkt der
aufmerksamkeit standen aber nicht die
pressekonferenz und ich glaube man hat
einfach keine neue veränderungen und
große veränderungen mit dieser
pressekonferenz verbunden und an sich
haben wir auch gesehen empfehlen neues
wurde auch nicht erreicht aber klar
erwartet bei dieser pressekonferenz
gesagt sollte genau wie oft hat ja
durchaus einen manchmal berüchtigten ruf
zu verteidigen
da hat man aber nicht erwartet ich
glaube was mich persönlich sehr
überrascht hat das in der sprache wie
hella bruch mit der deutschen
außenministerin gesprochen hat er war
sehr würde ich sagen höflich er hat
schon nach richtigen worten oder
richtige worte gewählt das ist nicht zu
vergleichen weil wir die
pressekonferenzen zum beispiel zwischen
herrn sagt worauf anschauen und im
amerikanischen kollegen man merkt sofort
dass die sprache ganz auf die sprache
geachtet werden er habe ich alle
beteuern er jetzt ihr eintreten für eine
friedliche lösung der konflikte um die
ukraine ja eigentlich auch um osteuropa
das geht er über die ukraine hinaus
waren das gestern in kiel von heute in
moskau
erste schritte in diese richtung
das ist zu früh das zu sagen wir wissen
nicht wirklich was hinter den kulissen
gespielt wird feststeht russland ist ein
problem für internationale und
europäische sicherheit derzeit aber
gleichzeitig müssen wir mit dem russland
wie es ist leben und umgehen und ich
denke wir brauchen jetzt so was wie eine
realpolitische front bereinigung mit
russland über den preis muss man reden
aber ich denke dass man mit russland
verhandeln kann und wenn man verhandeln
will muss man auch was bieten und man
muss jetzt sagen wie man von a nach b
kommt und da ist die deutsche
außenpolitik eine wichtige und deswegen
hat la france sich auch anständig
gegenüber frau burke jedenfalls
öffentlich benommen weil er weiß wenn
wir für ein stück weit auch auf
deutschland ankommt es kommt sicherlich
in erster linie auf die usa an aber auch
auf deutschland und diese realpolitische
begradigung die muss jetzt gemacht und
vor allen dingen vorbereiter verhalten
war also eher auch rücksicht auf die auf
deutschland ein wichtiger player in
diesem ganzen spielen man wird da auf
offener bühne kein streit vom zaun
brechen obwohl davor war das kann uns
schon gemacht hat aber ich glaube das
steht überhaupt nicht an jetzt alle
wissen was auf dem spiel steht und es
ist jetzt die stunde der diplomatie und
nicht der waffen und es ist gut dass
geredet wird und insofern habe ich
hoffnung dass da jetzt was in gang kommt
aber wir können ja noch mal über die
details reden das ist sehr schwierig wir
hören uns noch etwas anderes aus dieser
pressekonferenz ab wieder von annalena
baerbock irgendein china das gerade
schon erwähnt da wir wollen uns noch
diese passage anhören wo die deutsche
außenministerin doch recht geschickt
vergangenheit und gegenwart der deutsch
russischen beziehungen verwoben hat
sehr geehrter kollege lawrow vor unserem
treffen habe ich im namen der
bundesregierung und im namen meiner
landsleute dem grab des unbekannten
soldaten unseren respekt bezeugt
dort als deutsche außenministerin zu
stehen erfüllt mich mit charme und
ehrfurcht wir die wir politische
verantwortung tragen haben keine
wichtigere pflicht als unsere
bevölkerung zu schützen
vor allen dingen vor krieg und gewalt
ich bin überzeugt das können wir am
besten durch erfolgreiche gespräche
erreichen nicht gegeneinander sondern
miteinander
er wurde das war ja möglicherweise ein
ganz kluger schachzug von an der burg
das so viel zu verbinden vergangenheit
und gegenwart es geht ja letztendlich
darum dass auch die deutschen interessen
die deutschen argumente in diesem
konflikt in moskau gehör bekommen werden
denn diese argumente von annalena
baerbock in moskau diese auch
vorgetragen hat zum gesamten konflikt
durchaus verfangen werden die da gehört
werden wird man die ernst nehmen
natürlich wenn die gehört ich glaube nur
man muss
die sätze von frau bär wird nochmal
ergänzen es ist nämlich so dass russland
natürlich in der regel vom westen
angegriffen worden ist das war ja nicht
nur die hitler und die deutschen
das war ja auch napoleon das war auch
carla 12 geschont und immer gingen an
über die flächen von heute belarus ist
also weißrussland und über die ukraine
weil das sozusagen eine nicht
verteidigungs fähige gebiet ein nicht
verteidigungs fähiges gerät ist ein
flaches gebiet in dem es keine
möglichkeit gibt sich zu verschanzen und
russland musste immer die westlichen
armeen hineinlassen napoleon bis moskau
die deutschen bis wenige kilometer vor
moskau
und man muss ausgeben was frau wolff
gesagt hat auch die schlussfolgerung
ziehen warum russland die seinerseits
und insbesondere die russen ob das bei
coutie so ist macht man darüber streiten
aber die russen haben natürlich ein
unsicherheitsgefühl ging damit im westen
und um fragen wie man in russland
gemacht hat zeigen und sie haben
natürlich die nato als eine feindliche
organisation mehr des kalten krieges
erlebt also wenn man den gedanken
kontroverser zu ende
dann muss man so glaube ich zu dem
ergebnis kommt
das was sie gesagt hat hin am grab des
unbekannten soldaten in moskau das ist
auch eine bestätigung
dessen was aus russischer seite aus
russischer sicht vielleicht in der
gegenwärtigen lage gesehen wird also man
darf die russische innenpolitik und das
sicherheitsgefühl wir müssen selber darf
man nicht unterschätzen
und ich finde dieser zusammenhang sollte
gerade an dieser stelle noch einmal
unterstrichen doch nicht kommt nachher
genau auf diesen aspekt auch nochmal zu
sprechen jürgen trittin
es geht ja darum dass die argumente
überzeugen der deutschen seite direkt
die bundesministerin dort vor jetzt
haben wir ja schon mehrfach gehört und
wissens auch sergej lavrov ist ein
harter knochen und möglicherweise wird
er mit einem außenpolitischen konzept
einer werte basierten außenpolitik auch
fremden was muss man tun um die
russische seite da mit eigenen
argumenten wirklich zu überzeugen
lassen sie mich noch mal an dem beispiel
anknüpfen wir haben auch gegenüber
russland eine historische verantwortung
mein vater ist im alter von 17 jahren
mit der waffen ss nach russland in die
damalige sowjetunion einmarschiert es
bis kurz vor moskau gekommen sie können
im stadtgebiet moskau heute noch die
stände sehen wo die deutschen panzer
gestoppt worden sind und dieses stück
verantwortung zu betonen ist die
grundvoraussetzung um mit russland über
die auch für russland unbequem war
halten zu sprechen ja
gerade weil das so ist wie hat man ja
gesagt hat hat die nato in der
vereinbarung zwischen der nato und
russland sich selber verpflichtet keine
truppen dauerhaft auf dem gebiet des
ehemaligen warschauer paktes zu
stationieren hier ist dem
sicherheitsbedürfnis
der russischen seite ausdrücklich
entgegen gekommen und in kenntnis dieser
geschichte hat mal die sowjetunion mit
gorbatschow
auf der basis der schlussakte von
helsinki die verträge von paris mit
unterzeichnet und ratifiziert
die die unverletzlichkeit der grenzen
das verbot der einseitigen und
gewaltsamen veränderung von grenzen und
die freie bündnis war festgeschrieben
hat und wir werden mit russland um deren
sicherheitsbedürfnisse tatsächlich auch
ernst zu nehmen und zu respektieren
dieses tun müssen auf dieser grundlage
und ich glaube diese beiden dinge
gehören zusammen die für historische
verantworten die gerade deutsche
gegenüber russland haben aber auch die
verantwortung die russland eingegangen
ist in den verträgen die sie über die
sicherheit und die zusammenarbeit in
europa selber geschlossen dann können
wir jetzt das inhaltlich vielleicht
vorziehen was ich später fragen wollte
nervig
wenn wir uns die perspektive der russen
zu eigen macht genügt ja ein blick auf
den globus ich erhebe schwere da könnte
man ja tatsächlich der meinung sein
russland ist ein geist im osten von
alaska im südosten von china im süden
von indien von den muslimischen ländern
im westen von europa haben wir in
westeuropa haben wir überhaupt im westen
zu wenig dieses russische gefühl der
einkreisung ob es nun wirklich real ist
oder ob es ein gebildet ist haben wir
das zu wenig beachtet ja ich würde sagen
deutlich ja in der außenpolitik ist
herceptin realität und wir müssen uns
nicht die russische sichtweise zu eigen
machen aber wir müssen versuchen die
russische sichtweise ein stück zu
verstehen und da ist es eben so dass
russland sich gewissermaßen als
verlierer der europäischen sicherheits
ordnung versteht und mehrfach versuche
gemacht hat das zu thematisieren und im
westen darauf keine reaktion bekommen
hat der letzte versuch war der
sogenannte medwedew plan 2008 das hat
der westen sozusagen kühl ignoriert und
jetzt glaube ich versucht russland in
einer neuen geopolitischen lage ein
stoppschild zu setzen was eine
annäherung der ukraine an nato und
europäische union angeht und russland
macht das mit völlig ungewöhnlichen
mitteln ich will das überhaupt nicht
beschönigen aber ich sehe dass er
gewissermaßen als eine art hilfe
versuche über die europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur neu zu verhandeln
und wir sollten nicht naiv sein russland
ist gefährlich russland ist eine
revisionistische macht aber gleichzeitig
müssen wir mit dem russland umgehen wie
es ist und ich glaube es gibt ein großes
delta zwischen verharmlosung und piment
und dem angebot für faire verhandlungen
über prinzipien der europäischen
sicherheits ordnung wo russland einen
neuen platz brauchen das ist eine
langzeit vorstellung die nicht heute auf
dem tisch liegt aber daran müssen wir
arbeiten und daran müssen wir mit
russland im gespräch bleiben und vor
allen dingen auch die
sicherheitsbedürfnisse der russen nicht
vom tisch wischen und sagen wie der nato
sind doch die guten rücken immer näher
dran aber nichts gutes das verfängt wird
er wusste nicht wer wird denn wenn diese
ängste der russen in der ukraine auch
wahrgenommen oder wird das überlagert
einfach von der bedrohung 100000
soldaten mit gerät dann vor allem an der
grenze der ost ukraine
ich wollte eigentlich auch das thema
historischer verantwortung ansprechen
ich finde auch deutschland trägt auch
eine historische verantwortung vor der
ukraine es ist immer schwierig ich
glaube auch in deutschland zu erklären
was das bedeutet der ukraine ich
versuche das an meinem beispiel
ich bin in einem kleinen dorf in der
ukraine aufgewachsen auf einem kleinen
fleck der erde
sind circa 3000 juden in der nähe von
von von meinem zuhause erschossen fünf
kilometer weiter von uns wohnte meiner
oma meine oma und mehr als 15 verwandte
in meiner familie wurden erschossen das
ganze dorf oder erschossen ich möchte
nur damit sagen dass dieser historische
verantwortung die wir den ländern
gegenüber tragen in deutschland soll
auch gar keinen fall als eine grundlage
für die politik sein und das was ich
sehe in deutschland dass wir immer auf
diesen schuldgefühlen aufbauen und die
politik gegenüber russland so gestalten
wie schuldgefühl das sind keine
grundlage in einer ehe und die
funktionieren auch nicht in den
beziehungen zwischen den staaten und ich
appelliere dazu dass man auf die
schuldgefühle verzichtet weil sonst wenn
jeder jetzt versucht auf diese
schuldgefühle einzugehen und zu sagen
wir haben das erlebt und wir haben noch
das erlebt dann haben wir keine zukunft
das heißt diese diese schuldgefühle
verbringen dann werde deutschland zum
beispiel entschuldigt ganz kurz tritt
ihnen noch eine nachfrage an frau
melanie diese schuldgefühle sind denn
die verhindern also eine klare deutsche
die formulierung klarer deutscher
interessen auf europäischer entlassen
auch klarer interessen gegenüber
russland wir lassen euch wir lassen euch
diese aggressive politik nicht
durchgehen ich finde das wird einfach
manipulierten dieser schuldgefühlen weil
ihr gesagt wenn ich einfach vergleiche
was die ukraine erlebt hat und das heute
wie er in der ukraine gar keine ängste
haben gegenüber deutschland sondern mehr
als glaube als 12.000 studenten
studieren in deutschland sind wir haben
und pflegen auch die beziehungen zu
deutschland aber wir bauen nicht darauf
was sozusagen deutschland damals gemacht
hat ich glaube darauf sollten wir
verzichten
ich würde dem widersprechen es geht
nicht um schuldgefühle es geht um
verantwortung
es geht also nicht um irgendetwas zu
fühlen sondern es geht darum sich im
verhalten konkret zu der historischen
verantwortung zu stellen und ausdruck
genau dieser historischen verantwortung
war es dass es in den verträgen von
paris regeln gegeben hat diesen regeln
verbieten es sich in irgendeiner form
auf die geschichte zu berufen weder die
deutschen die mal gesungen haben von der
maas bis an die memel noch russland die
behaupten die krim sei schon immer
russisch und ukrainisch gewesen genau
ausdruck der historischen verantwortung
ist diese friedensordnung und das hat
nichts mit schuldgefühlen zu tun und die
zweite bemerkungen die ich machen möchte
ist man muss auch an so einer stelle
auch ordnungs in richtung russland mal
klar sehen dass es ja auch
unterschiedliche positionen gibt
natürlich ist die stationierung einer
raketenabwehr durch die usa unilateral
ohne nato zustimmung ist sie stationiert
worden inzwischen ist das anders dass
diese stationierung geschehen ist gegen
einwände aus deutschland gegen einwände
aus frankreich und selbstverständlich
war es so dass in den frühen 2000er
jahren der wunsch der bush
administration
eines baldigen beitritt georgiens und
der ukraine zur nato nicht die
zustimmung gefunden hat
deutschlands und frankreichs
das heißt wir haben es mit einer
komplexen situation zu tun und wenn ich
das aufgreifen was er mag ich gesagt hat
ja ich finde es gibt vorschläge die auf
dem tisch liegen ich erinnere an die
idee
dieser tage die ein angebot an russland
darstellen aber ein angebot auf der
basis der europäischen
sicherheitsarchitektur
und nicht auf der basis einer revision
dessen was wir in europa in historische
verantwortung als grundlage für
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit gelegt
jetzt würde ich gerne aber auf die
aktuelle deutsche außenpolitik
zurückgehen herr von dohnanyi es gibt ja
durchaus auseinandersetzungen zwischen
der position der bundesaußenminister in
auch im konflikt mit russland oder in
der frage wie man mit der ukraine umgeht
auch wie man reagiert sollte es
tatsächlich zu einer militärischen
aktion gegen die ukraine kommen und der
spd den kanzler stellt ihrer partei die
sich da zurück hält sich bedeckt hält
die
sanktionsmöglichkeiten da nicht so für
bedeutend hält zumindestens was nord
stream 2 angeht da gibt es ja auch
streit mit der mit den bündnisgrünen
wie muss das in moskau dann aufgenommen
werden wenn da möglicherweise die
deutsche bundesregierung in dieser frage
mit gespaltener zunge spricht
ein klima ich würde doch gerne einen
augenblick auf herrn trittin noch einmal
eingehen weil das was sie gesagt haben
herr trittin ja nicht ganz präzise ist
die entscheidung im jahr 2008 im nato
rat in kuba will es ist ja nicht so
gewesen dass deutschland und frankreich
den beitritt der ukraine verhindern
konnten sondern es ist beschlossen
worden die tür aufzumachen für einen
späteren beitritt der ukraine
und genau diese war der formelkompromiss
nochmal sekunde bis dann ihr ein
kompromiss aber zugunsten letzten endes
eine offene tür für die geredet und
dieser diese situation ist dann noch mal
auf eine finde ich unverantwortlicher
weise vom generalsekretär der nato im
juni des vergangenen jahres am 21 juni
noch einmal bestätigt worden mit einem
ausdrücklichen beschluss
die ukraine werde in den dann
beeindrucken zugleich aber haben wir
eine völlig verrückte andere lage in
china der vorsitzende der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz konferenz und ein
wirklich sehr informiert man auf diesem
sektor und zugleich ein früherer
staatssekretär des auswärtigen amtes hat
im jahr 2018 vor vier jahren geschrieben
es sei im bündnis längst beschlossen
dass die ukraine nicht in die naht
bekommen und ich kann nicht verstehen
warum diese feststellung die in den
letzten tagen noch einmal von der rand
corporation in amerika bestätigt worden
ist ich kann nicht verstehen
warum wir das nicht nutzen um einen
ersten schritt in der entspannung zu tun
der nach der
das heißt er wäre für die kooperation
gesprochen als er hat eine überschrift
in seinem artikel die nato muss sich
endlich ehrlich machen ehrlich machen
dass sie das gar nicht will und deswegen
bin ich der meinung dass wir im grunde
genommen eine völlig verfahrene
situation weswegen haben weil
irgendjemand vielleicht ist es präsident
biden selbst nicht in der lage ist
wirklich klar zu sagen was wir haben
sehr klar sagen sondern es ist so dass
die nato nicht in die ukraine hinein
brennen und dass wir für die ukraine
eine sonderlösung finden wie finnland
sie hat wie österreich sie hat mich
werden sie hatten irland sie hat also
für die neutralen staaten in europa dann
wären wir längst aus dieser krise heraus
mindestens auf einer verhandlungsphase
die mit es mit kot ihn sehr viel
leichter machen will und ich finde durch
diese haltung des westens durch diese
male ehrlichkeit des westen haben wir
letzten endes putin provoziert ein
solches veto einzulegen das wäre nie
passiert wenn ihr eine kluge politik
gemacht und dadurch haben jetzt
ausführlich dokumentiert was die
vorgeschichte dieses konfliktes ist man
muss ja auch noch zur
nato-mitgliedschaft dazu sagen die steht
ja offensichtlich nicht zur debatte ein
land darf keine inneren konflikt in die
nato mit reinbringen demokratie und
rechtsstaat müsse gesichert sein dass
land muss auch die kosten der nato
mittragen können alle drei punkte
treffen für die ukraine im moment ja
ganz offensichtlich
ich würde gerne jetzt mal auf den arm
allen auf den aktuellen aspekt eingehen
es ist ja immer dieses wort von ihr alt
hat 20 die rede es wird nämlich jalta
der vertrag von jalta hat ja europa in
zwei teile gespalten das war der
ausgangspunkt ein wesentlicher
ausgangspunkt des ost west konfliktes
das soll jetzt russland sozusagen wieder
erneuern nach der nach dem zerfall der
sowjetunion
1990 zur aufteilung in interessensphären
das soll das russische ziel sein auch
bezüglich mancher osteuropäischer
ehemaliger
sowjet-republiken ist das ein
realistisches ziel steckt das
tatsächlich dahinter die art wir sehen
schon eine art geopolitische ja
entschuldigung
so nahmen auch zustimmen er hat recht
mit seiner analyse sich teile dafür
wollen wir sehen eine politisierung des
euroatlantischen raum ist und wir müssen
über sowas wie einflusszonen regen mir
gefällt das auch nicht mir wäre lieber
wenn sozusagen die ganze welt harmonisch
wäre und wir alle gleiche interessen
hätten aber so ist es nicht in der
internationalen politik die
internationale politik ist quasi
alltäglich gekennzeichnet von
unterschiedlichen ordnungsvorstellungen
und es kommt auch hier zum tragen und
ich glaube dass wir ein stück weit
akzeptieren müssen dass russland eine
andere ordnung vorstellung als wir hat
akzeptieren heißt nicht billigen aber
akzeptieren in dem sinne dass man
darüber nachdenkt wie man gedeihlich in
dieser situation miteinander umgehen
kann und wir kennen eigentlich den preis
den wir zahlen müssen um mit russland
wieder zu einem besseren verhältnis zu
kommen der preis wäre wie er von
dohnanyi ist richtig sagte dass wir in
der frage der nato-erweiterung ein
klares statement abgeben dass die
politik der offenen tür gewissermaßen zu
ende ist und die ukraine nicht nato
mitglied wird und auch konzeptionell
nicht werden sollte sondern in einer art
ja schwierig zwischen zone pufferzone
alles böse worte liegt aber ich glaube
das wäre am ende auch im ukrainischen
interesse und wir dürfen das natürlich
nicht ohne beteiligung der ukraine
verhandeln das ist völlig klar aber das
wäre ein ausgangspunkt für ein
arrangement in der noch in der
europäischen sicherheitspolitik auf
dessen basis wir wieder über gemeinsame
interessen reden können die es auch gibt
mit russland etwa im bereich
rüstungskontrolle etwa im bereich
klimawandel etwa im bereich
terrorismusbekämpfung eine lange liste
an gemeinsamkeiten die jetzt völlig aus
dem blick geraten weil die lage so
verbrauchen braucht es diese zusicherung
gegenüber russland explizit weil wenn
man sich das mal ansieht wenn die
ukraine und georgien in die nato
aufgenommen werden würden würde ja alles
sieht man auf der landkarte ja sehr gut
die ostflanke derartig über den die
ostflanke der nato russland im norton
die türkei als nicht so sicherer kanton
ist im süden will das überhaupt jemand
im westen ich würde nicht sagen ob es
das braucht aber das ist sozusagen das
wäre jetzt ein ausgangspunkt für
verhandlungen und der russland hat ja
vor weihnachten seine vorstellungen zur
europäischen sicherheitsarchitektur auf
den tisch gelegt die sind für uns
inakzeptabel weil da auch so dinge drin
stehen die man am ende dann so aus
buchstabieren müsste das etwa die das
baltikum sozusagen ein einst mitglied
zweiter klasse in der nato wäre das ist
sicherlich nicht akzeptabel aber ich
glaube für uns akzeptabel wäre dass die
politik der offenen tür verändern weil
zumal wir auch nicht bereit sind das
muss man auch mal deutlich sagen für die
ukraine nicht nur nicht in den krieg zu
ziehen dass wir sowieso niemand es wird
kein deutscher soldat und auch kein
nato-soldat für die ukraine den krieg
ziehen wir werden aber auch nicht bereit
seien harte wirtschaftssanktionen für
die ukraine den kauf zu nehmen dinge wie
es hilft oder an nordstream dafür sind
wir gar nicht bereit das heißt wir sind
im prinzip gar nicht eskalation fähig
und auch nicht eskalation willig und auf
dieser basis wäre es klug ein
interessensausgleich hin zu bekommen
oder dass zumindest das sieht man
möglicherweise in der ukraine anders
wenn ich diese erklärung die jetzt da
praktisch eingefordert worden ist dass
man eigentlich den nato erweiterung der
ukraine ausschließen soll eine art
neutralisierung des landes ja von
anderen ländern finnland visierung nennt
sich das ja in der strategischen
geschichte das ist ja eigentlich mit mit
der ukraine nicht zu machen die erwartet
sich ja etwas anderes sie vertraut
diesen neutralen status wahrscheinlich
nicht und wäre dann ja eigentlich wieder
oder würde ja wieder
zu interessensphäre russlands gehören
und die woche hatten bereits eigentlich
2010 1 1 viktor janukowitsch an der
macht war ein vertrag unterschrieben
dass die ukraine eine trainer stark ist
und bleibt und wir wissen wozu das alles
geführt hat 2014 erfolgte die annexion
danach erfolgte die nächste aggression
russlands ich bin auch für die dieser
neutrale staat sozusagen das hat damals
nichts gebracht und ich glaube der
ukrainer kann man heute nichts
versprechen wenn die ukraine noch mal
neutrale wird dann werden auch würden
würde russland keine weiteren
territorien annektieren
zweitens was ich auch betonen möchte wir
sprechen über die ukraine als ob die
ukraine kein keine mündige bevölkerung
hat mehr als 53 prozent der bevölkerung
sind für die nato spektive und das ist
nicht jetzt eine neue tendenz sondern
das entwickelt sich über viele jahre
wenn die ukraine dem
sicherheitsbedürfnis der menschen
das ist und das kann man nicht
bestreiten ich kann mir gar nicht das
ist wie ein politischer selbstmord wenn
jemand jetzt in deren trainer kommt und
sagt vielen dank wir haben die truppen
an der grenze aber wir verzichten auf
die nato mitgliedschaft oder wir werden
uns dafür nicht bewerben klar man weiß
um die ukraine ganz genau das wird nicht
in den nächsten jahren passieren aber
was kann der westen oder was kann der
westen überhaupt anderes anbieten und
die den dritter moment den ich auch
ansprechen möchte
heute sprechen wir über nato rund bei
diesem konflikt zwischen nato und
russland
2014 sprachen wir darüber dass
eigentlich russland sich dafür
eingesetzt hat die russischsprachige
bevölkerung in der ukraine zu schützen
der konflikt an sich hat sich nicht
geändert die sprache darüber und wie wir
darüber sprechen hat sich geändert
damals war dass alles was gemacht wurde
nur um die russischsprachigen
bevölkerung in der ukraine zu schützen
die russischsprachige bevölkerung lebt
weiter allerdings die schulen die
ukrainischen schulen sind geschlossen
auf der krim gibt es gar keine
möglichkeiten die ukrainische sprache zu
lernen
in den besetzten gebieten gar keine
möglichkeiten sogar die ukrainische
fächer zu unterrichten und zu erlernen
die schüler machen online unter richter
und versuchen das über schulen zu machen
die in der ukraine nicht in den
besetzten gebieten
sind und ich glaube heute ich frage mich
nur was wenn wir heute damals gesagt war
dass diese russischsprachige stand im
mittelpunkt jetzt haben wir nato
russland konflikt was wird dann in den
nächsten zehn jahren passieren welchen
diskurs werden wir noch mal erleben
wenn
bleibt ist dabei dass russland möchte
dass die ukraine nicht in die nato geht
oder dass die nato das auch wirklich
zusagt und verspricht oder geht es
möglicherweise noch um andere gebiete in
osteuropa die einem irgendwann mal zum
sowjetischen einflussbereich gehört hat
bleibt die drahtlos land da wirklich bei
der ukraine stehen oder müssen sich da
auch noch andere staaten gedanken machen
dass russland fordert dass es eigentlich
die interessen russlands zu vertreten
hat wie zum beispiel das baltikum
nein ich glaube es geht in erster linie
gegen wti um die gewalten staaten in
erster linie die ukraine aber auch um
georgien die einmal wirkliche teile des
russischen reiches waren und auch der
sowjetunion waren das muss man sehen und
ich glaube wir müssen uns einfach
realistisch damit auseinandersetzen dass
auf tour gehen natürlich eine
innenpolitik hat
und wenn man bedenkt dass er
innenpolitisch ja auch eventuell mal
abgelöst werden könnte später vielleicht
von einem wirklichen wachsender sitzen
einem ganz abschaffen dann weiß man doch
nicht was es bedeutet wenn man ihm heute
sozusagen die ukraine als ein teil des
nato gebietes mit am ende amerikanischen
soldaten in kiew
anbietet als eine lösung das kann nicht
die lösung sein deswegen ich komme noch
einmal darauf zurück wir müssen
versuchen den weg zu gehen den echinger
offenbar vorgeschlagen hat ihn übrigens
gehörte und harte geo politiker der usa
wiesen ski schon im jahr 2014
vorgeschlagen nämlich einen weg zu
finden indem eine art finnland visierung
wie man das nennt der ukraine
stattfindet und dann kann die
ukrainische auf denselben
militärischen schutz bekommen den wir
sage ich mal finden oder auch schweden
aussprechen würden aber eben nicht in
die nato kommen und nicht als teil der
nato an der russischen grenze sein und
das ist glaube ich der anfang lösungen
und wenn man das erstmal erreicht hat
und im westen den mut hat das
auszusprechen was ohne in wirklichkeit
inzwischen wenn man das gemacht hat dann
kann man davon bin ich fest überzeugt
über die anderen dinge mit putin auch
sehr hart reden denn seine forderung die
im übrigen stellt sind ja wirklich
inakzeptabel allerdings muss man auch
sehen dass der amerikanische präsident
roosevelt in die nach ihrer im märz
1945 gesagt hat der yalta vertrag gebe
zum ersten mal europa eine stabilität
wie europa nie vorher gehabt habe also
insofern ist der putin wenn man so will
mit seiner these dass sei ein
politisches desaster gewesen
nicht ganz alleine wohl in europa dann
auch wirklich stabilität für europa
bedeutet da gibt es wahrscheinlich
historiker schweiz herr trittin nato
nicht an der russischen grenze das haben
wir ja bereits es sind ja drei staaten
und zwar auch starte neben der
ehemaligen sowjetunion der union der
sozialistischen sowjetrepubliken nämlich
estland lettland litauen litauen sind ja
in der nato mit direkten kontakt
geografisch zu russland was muss die
deutsche politik tun oder was wird sie
machen wenn das was putin jetzt gerade
mit der ukraine vor hat auch auf das
baltikum ausdehnt
ich glaube dass es hier einen
wesentlichen unterschied gibt auch
russland hat immer die besondere rolle
der baltischen staaten gewinnen sie sind
mitglied der nato aber lassen sie mich
noch eine bemerkung zu diesem modell der
finalisierung machen
sehen sie das wird in der ukraine mit
gutem grund oder mit historischer
berechtigung außerordentlich skeptisch
gesehen 23 länder gegeben die der
ukraine sicherheit und territoriale
integrität versprochen haben von
großbritannien die usa und russland um
den preis dass die ukraine nach dem
zerfall der sowjetunion die ich dort
stationierten atomwaffen abgegeben hat
das innerhalb der ukraine
misstrauen gegenüber solchen garantien
besteht verstehe ich und deswegen ist
dieser analogie zu der frage finnland
vielleicht etwas vereinfacht man wird
wenn man den russischen
sicherheitsinteressen berechtigt
entgegen komplett und die stimme hallen
zu es wird die nächsten zehn jahre
keinen beitritt der ukraine und
georgiens zur nato geben das kann man
auch so sagen es war übrigens deswegen
habe ich auf die bukarest hingewiesen
herr von dohnanyi
die deutsche bundesregierung die die
aufnahme in den membership action plan
also den start des formellen beitrag
beitrittsverfahren somit blockiert hat
das hat offensichtlich nicht ausgereicht
das sicherheitsgefühl von einem putin zu
erhöhen sonst hat er 2014 nicht die krim
annektiert an dieser stelle nur das
prinzip ist etwas schwieriger als nur zu
sagen finnland easy rung es sind
elemente des sicherheits und des
legitimen sicherheitsinteressen der
ukraine ebenso zu berücksichtigen wie
des legitimen sicherheitsinteressen
russlands und wir müssen uns klar machen
selbstverständlich kenne ich den wunsch
der ukraine ich glaube es sogar in der
verfassung mittlerweile festgeschrieben
der nato beizutreten das verpflichtet
die nato nicht sie aufzunehmen und das
muss man auch sagen aber dann muss man
eine antwort darauf haben wie die
künftige
zukunft der ukraine ist die sich ja
offenbar sehr deutlich dafür entschieden
hat über engere politische und
wirtschaftliche beziehungen zur
europäischen union das war ja nicht
irgendwo singt ein ausgangspunkt zur
nato nämlich die auseinandersetzung die
auf dem majdan dann ihren blutigen
höhepunkt gefunden hat genau diese
entwicklung auch tatsächlich abzusichern
das wird ein sehr komplexer sehr
schwieriger verhandlungsprozess bevor
man zu einem solchen ergebnis kommt ich
stimme allen zu es wird am ende nicht
damit enden dass die ukraine und
georgien mitglieder der nato werden ich
habe diese länder haben berechtigte
sicherheitsinteressen ich würde gerne
nochmal über die die ukraine noch
hinausblicken manche halten ja das was
russland jetzt fordert für überflüssig
da geht es ja auch darum dass länder die
in der nato sind eigentlich gar keine
nato strukturen mehr haben sollten
entsteht da eine neue domino theorie
wenn jetzt die ukraine fällt wenn man
das zu sagen akzeptieren würde dass das
in den russischen nacht reich zurück
viele dass die anderen länder auch die
frage anderen farbig dass die anderen
länder da auch zum beispiel die
baltischen länder oder andere und
osteuropäische länder gefährdet werden
also wir sollten nicht so tun als ob es
darum ginge der ukraine jetzt den russen
zum fraß vorzuwerfen das ist nicht der
ansatz ebenfalls nicht meiner und ich
glaube auch nicht der von herrn von
dohnanyi und auch nicht von herr trittin
sondern es geht um einen fairen
interessensausgleich und deswegen ist
auch keine domino theorien sich zumal
ist richtig ist was er trittin sagt das
macht einen unterschied ob man nato
mitglied ist oder nicht deswegen wollen
ja auch so viele rein also dass im
baltikum jetzt irgend ein szenario droht
dass putin so verrückt wäre das baltikum
anzugreifen sehe ich überhaupt keine
anzeichen für und auch mal würde
schlichtweg keinen sinn machen die nato
hatte in den vergangenen jahren einiges
dafür getan ihre abschreckungsfähigkeit
gegen russland wieder herzustellen und
das ist auch vernünftig insofern ist das
naturgebiet sacrow sand und das wäre im
übrigen auch unser vitales interesse
dass da nichts schief geht und dass
weißrussland denke ich aber die ukraine
ist ein anderer fall und wir können
sozusagen über diese dinge glaube ich
mit russland reden und noch mal wir
müssen einen fairen interessensausgleich
suchen der für russland akzeptabel ist
der genauso auch für die ukraine
akzeptabel ist und der für uns
akzeptabel ist und ich glaube solche
formen formeln kammern finden
diplomatische verhandlungen wir sollten
aber keine roten linien definieren in
diesen verhandlungen jenseits des nato
gebietes wie sehr dieser
interessensausgleich aus ukrainischer
sicht aus was wird er die ukraine
beruhigen in diesem konflikt
ja offensichtlich auch wegen der
militärischen bedrohung an den
außengrenzen der ukraine ja angst vor
dieser entwicklung hat was würde die
ukraine was die ukrainische bevölkerung
beruhigen ich wollte noch auf die worte
von herrn trittin reagieren zum thema
verfassung das wurde nicht nur
außenpolitisch sozusagen vorgesehen oder
in der verfassung aufgenommen das ist
auch wichtig für die innenpolitische
lage wir wissen ganz genau dass es auch
politiker gab zum beispiel auch viktor
janukowitsch einen ganz anderen kurs
genommen hat und wir wissen auch dazu
wissen wozu das alles geführt hat
aber auch dieses misstrauen was herr
trittin angesprochen hat mit blick auf
das budapester memorandum es geht auch
nicht nur um das budapest am rand um
sondern mit blick auf die geschichte die
die ukraine hatte haben wir einen
einfach festgestellt dass sehr viele
viel leid der ukraine erlitten hatte und
unter der sowjetischen machte und sich
auch mal die frage antworten wenn ich
jetzt auf ihre frage kommen dann
die ukraine wird jetzt nicht verzichten
auf die die nato perspektive weil
heutzutage nichts neues gibt was was
diesen sicherheitsgefühl das in der
ukraine
verleihen kann was die finanzierung
angeht
soweit ich mich erinnern kann bevor das
überhaupt dazu kam staaten über 300.000
menschen in finnland die territorien
wurden annektiert und dann bekam finden
dann so ein status und eigentlich
verzichtete soweit ich weiss finnland
nicht darauf die nato mitgliedschaft das
steht finnland auch offen und ich glaube
wir dürfen einfach nicht jetzt sagen wir
sollen jetzt der ukraine einfach dieses
angebot unterbreiten und sagen jetzt
verzichten sie auf immer auf die nato
mitgliedschaft und das war bei kindern
nicht der fall und sollte eigentlich bei
den trainern nicht der fall sein die
finalisierung bezieht ich glaube ich
auch historisch auf die version des
kalten krieges in dem zwischen west und
ost einfach neutral bleiben sollten
trittin gegangen leider nur noch drei
minuten zeit ich würde gerne an sie noch
ein jahr warten bemerkungen man ja mit
kurze bemerkung hat ich verstehe das
nicht was die position der ukraine sie
erlebt gerade dass die nato ihr keine
sicherheit geben wird deswegen muss es
doch das interesse sein der ukraine eine
andere form zu finden dass ihr
sicherheit garantiert dass das ist doch
der punkt es wird dir nach einer
symbolischen wurst geschnappt die aber
in wirklichkeit schon lange nicht mehr
im schaufenster hängt jetzt richtig eine
frage noch zum schluss
russlands wohlstand hängt sehr stark von
energieexporten ab fossile energieträger
die möglicherweise demnächst im westen
in absehbarer zeit nicht mehr gebraucht
werden da verliert russland einen ganz
wichtigen export artikels droht auch
wirtschaftlicher niedergang erklärt dass
auch ein bisschen die russische position
im moment diese torschlusspanik da eines
tages auch ökonomisch abgehängt zu
werden
die dekarbonisierung europas wird dazu
führen dass russland einen wesentlichen
teil seiner staatsanleihen verliert und
das ist an der zeit auch in russlands
interesse sich auf diese zeit
vorzubereiten und deswegen ist das
angebot was annalena baerbock heute mit
brachte nämlich die zusammenarbeit
gerade bei der umstellung der
energiewirtschaft gemeinsam zu machen in
einem gemeinsamen europa ein angebot das
auch der im weiteren wohlstand und der
stabilität russlands dient das heißt
dann wäre quasi energie und klimapolitik
auch ein beil ein baustein für den
frieden in europa ein weites feld
eigentlich eine eigene sendung wir sind
am ende dieser sendung ich bedanke mich
wenn du mir melnik bei johannes warwick
bei klaus von dohnanyi und bei jürgen
trittin liebe zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde
österreich liegt vor im pflicht für alle
jetzt folgt für nichts der tag mit
constanze bratzke unter anderem geht es
auch um den besuch von annalena baerbock
heute in moskau was bei den weiteren
gesprächen mit sergey lavrov
möglicherweise gesprochen oder
vielleicht auch entschieden wurde ob es
wirklich ein erster schritt in richtung
deeskalation und verständigung bleiben
sie bei uns
[Musik]